welcome
I'm Joanna Smith, I'm here with Android Development
Pattern to show you our new model of permissions at run time
With Android Marshmallow.
So, let's take a look.
It is frightening to prove an application
Requires 14 different permissions.
But it's an application for Android Marshmallow
It can now ask the user permission at run time
Instead of the installation time.
Hopefully now, it will help avoid a fixation dialogue
Horrible like that.
And because run-time permissions are required for all
Programs that target Marshmallow, so
There are a few additional steps that will help you avoid exceptions
Horrible runtime.
Because, we all come across.
So in the beginning, make sure the platform.
Late run-time permissions are compatible with older SDKs versions
By reference to the original installation time request.
So if your user is on an older SDK,
You'll know that permissions are taken
When the application was installed.
If your user is on Marshmallow,
You can not be sure then.
This brings us to the next step,
Check the status of the permissions.
A simple call to checkSelfPermission
With the permission you care about
It will tell you whether the permission is granted or not.
If granted, you are ready to launch.
But if not granted, you will need to ask for it.
Note that you must conduct this investigation every time, because users
They can also revoke permissions now.
This in the end is very good for developers,
Even if it requires little extra work.
Because users will receive your order for permission
In the context that it provides clear justification and utility
for them.
This builds confidence at the user.
And let them say no thanks for a certain advantage
Maybe it makes them like you increase.
So we move on in our steps.
If you do not already have permission,
You can take a moment to explain why
This permission is required.
Draw your user a clear picture of the great potential of this feature
If you are given access to that source.
To help with this, there is a method
shouldShowRequestPermissionRationale
This will help you discover if you have some
Illustration to do.
The wrong method returns if the user asks
Question no longer ask or if permission
Hang on the device.
But the method will return correctly if the user previously refused
The permission now tries to access the property again
Because this is a sign that your user
May be nervous about app behavior.
So make it clear to them.
So you're ready to ask permission.
The requestPermissions method needs to be
The list of the permission you are interested in and the request code.
This asynchronous call will generate a user dialog
Their response will call back again,
This is why the demand symbol is so important
Which you specify.
It helps you locate the user of your app
And how to capture application behavior.
This brings us near the final step,
Dealing with permission results.
You can onRequestPermissionsResult,
Check the results of this connection.
If permission has been granted,
You can use the request code to return
To create an API connection and create
Magic moments for your user.
But if no permission has been granted,
You must accept the loss.
The easiest solution is to disable the property
With some kind of clear visual signal
That's because of the ear order.
So you can provide a dialog or update UI text.
But you probably want to keep
The UI layout is effective if you change your mind.
So do not disable this button.
Let them go back to the current when they care about it.
This is how to update your app
To handle the runtime permissions in Marshmallow.
One of my last tips
It's about testing these changes because it's not fun
Be kept hesitant between the application and its settings.
So check out the Package Order from the PackageManager
To grant and pull permissions programmatically
On the device.
Always, check the documentation at first.
Keep in mind that these changes
Meaning to help your user understand the behavior of your app.
So do not ask them for many permissions
cash all in one.
Put these permissions in context and build a better program.